today's topic lana rhodes has a podcast
called three girls in one kitchen
who lana rhodes she's a prawn star
oh okay oh
basically if you're not familiar with
the term hypergamy it means marrying
into
or having a sexual relationship with
someone of a higher sociological status
or education so that's basically
hypergamy
hypergamy hypergamy hypergamy
okay and so on tumblr it's like a huge
community that's actually where i got
the idea for today's topic
of trophy wife training
to trophy wife training here's the rule
uh number one of trophy why shut the
[ __ ] up
you're done someone's a trophy wife
you're meant to be seen not heard
yeah absolutely definitely you're a
trophy you're not the first lady you're
an
object this episode we're not going to
preach to you guys about how to be the
perfect woman for a man
this episode is more about how to become
a more well-rounded woman for yourself
yeah and that will obviously draw in a
high value man
and i think that's the 20 21 definition
i think that's like the rebranded
trophy wife is that it's not just about
looking good you know like if you want
to have hairy legs and hairy armpits
you go girl like you do that if that
makes you confident and you get a man
like that like that's i support that you
know we i feel like we just support
everything and it's about
yeah if you want to have a trophy in the
corner with smudges and [ __ ] rust on
it
go girl but that's not that's not a
trophy nobody wants that trophy
stop lying okay this whole like
inclusive
no but i think gold digger i think
that's what she's about to say
but let's see how you feel and woman
empowerment
um you know like not necessarily being a
trophy wife requires you to always look
attractive
some men think that
you see why i don't have hope some men
think that you know
brains is a turn on for them so it's
what they value and their eyes what
makes
you a trophy wife or what you value to
become
a complete woman then that's not a
trophy wife
call it women empowerment that's what it
is i'm a provider you know i mean
maybe not financially but like in good
conversations in a good company
i really got a job but i'll provide you
with a body at home
that's not a provider you can't just
change the definition of stuff
and then run with it like yeah well this
is what we want to be no you're a bum
because i want to take the negativity
out of that that word
i'm going to rebrand it that's not what
it is i swear these people a gold digger
is a gold digger and it's okay that
she's a golden girl be a gold digger
that's how you make your money boo boo
and there's some men that want that
do you boo boo if these goofballs have
either way
yeah i promise you the english language
is gonna mean nothing i actually have a
great
analogy for you guys which i don't think
i've shared with you guys
before when i was in prison
bro sister set up the [ __ ] shame and
they [ __ ] shine something
he sexy eyes
yo what's miley from ranks to riches the
trophy
no you can't kell set up kell
set up
we used to do a group in my cottage
which was the drug cottage
very good wrap it up all right
um no um no listen that's what we
thought that's it for them
no no no my plans haven't hatched to
full fruition yet
let us proceed you know i had a friend
who was dating like a beautiful girl a
really hot model
that like she's just a gorgeous girl
dropped out gorgeous every guy in l.a
would love to date her
and he would say that he couldn't be
with her because she's had too many
sexual partners
and he only dated her because he wanted
a trophy wife or a girlfriend
yes a trophy that's been passed around
hundreds of times
doesn't have the same value as a trophy
that you get for yourself if you're
looking for a trophy
it's meant to be for a winner you want
to feel special
doesn't make you know what it's like
it's like the dudes who talk about like
high value man but they broke
this is the other end of that spectrum
yeah these are the girls who got peed
and put on
trying to be trophy wives it's like boo
boo this trophy coming out with doo doo
stains on it
and you like why wouldn't you accept me
because there's three trophies down
there
because you're clean because you're here
look let's do the round
through the rounds it's through the
round
around i think sometimes in a
relationship where
some guys just might get bored and they
just want to bring something up from the
past to use against you or even just
when they fight in general like
it could be over bringing the wrong cup
of coffee for your significant other and
then that
argument is just going to downfall to
well you've slept to so many people
you're a [ __ ] you know
just because they want to use something
against you
can i get an espresso brought you
cappuccino you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
hey babe sorry i need to put it back in
the microwave you
[ __ ] dirty [ __ ] make it make sense
it's how you value yourself if you it
said in the book that we read why
men love [ __ ] is that if you value
yourself as a prize
they will see you as a prize as well for
example in the past i've said
a girl cannot be the prettiest on the
outside but if
a girl comes up to me and she's like
damn i'm so hot i'm the hottest girl in
this room
i'm gonna double look at her and be like
is she the hottest girl in this room no
you're gonna be like no [ __ ] she's not
damn right who the [ __ ] she what she
thinks she's the hotter [ __ ] in the
room no she's not how about this who the
hell you think she is
how about how about this how many times
have an ugly man come up to you with all
the confidence in the world and you're
like
you were like damn is this
quasimodo looking [ __ ] brad pitt
no stop lying this is kind of the usual
double speak that people do to
themselves
to make themselves think they can be
anything [ __ ] if you five four you
always gonna be 5'4
no i'm fine all right once you get
pissed and pulled on
that's going to be part of your history
it is what it is once you get pissed and
put on your stain
you can't be a trophy wife you can't
which and it's fine it's okay
majority of people are not trophy wives
damn right majority of wives are not
trophy wives
majority of guys are not top tier there
you go
so we go i could go get any boob job
today
but it wouldn't make me feel as good as
i feel about being smart and educated
and i think education also or just
educating yourself
there's no limit bro isn't this the most
basic thing
it is it's basically did you not see
that starbucks cup it's stupid super
basic did you see that stuff
spiced pumpkin yeah you think so latte
can we check their feet let's go for
what
ug boots
obviously i've experienced this a ton
because of my past
guys will be fine with it at the
beginning then as those feelings start
to develop they start getting insecure
and jealous the more in love with you
they are and then they start questioning
they start going and watching the stuff
and then they start questioning you
about it
and they just get very insecure in
themselves and so i've they go watch
this stuff because the stuff is
the stuff is out there honey you put it
out i mean
it comes with a cost okay they live in
this fantasy world where
yo i'm gonna do everything that i want
to do and it's not gonna come out of
cost or something
comfortable it do it do they do it will
who would get married with somebody
find out they got a criminal record and
one check into it who would marry
somebody find out they got like
videos of them singing in front of
millions people and wouldn't go watch it
if you're with somebody you're going to
look into it if it's online of course
oh but abba you're sex shaming no no
that's not what it is
i'm just not shaming it's not what it is
there's a
cost people peop that's how the society
works damn right
you know the society views it that's
right
i'm not saying it's right or wrong i
view it like that but don't be surprised
when it happens
i've even like had that happen with
myself as well where i'm super cool at
the beginning of a relationship then
maybe
something happens or just like those
feelings develop and then you sort of
just
become like the love sometimes makes you
act in a way that you wish that you
didn't
i've definitely been like that i've been
in relationships where i'm like i don't
know why i'm picking this fight today
but
back to being like who's this girl who
is this girl is the
woman version of [ __ ]
so so you say you don't want that
because you want to get him a coffee i
didn't get that
but you're doing the same thing you
realize you even realize you're doing
the same
press play but do you guys think that i
should a lot of people tell me oh you'll
never be married
why would anyone want to date you do you
think i should be excluded from ever
being considered a trophy wife because
of my past no it'll be
yeah trophy wife life no trophy wife
absolutely should be excluded
you shouldn't got the requirements it's
like should me [ __ ] 30 guys mean i'm
excluded
from like being a virgin yes i'm not
saying you should strive to be a virgin
i'm just saying you can't be one okay
this whole like new thing where everyone
can just say they are what they are
i'm 10 years old you're not 10. i'm a
born-again version no
no you're not you're a [ __ ] sorry
let me rephrase god damn bro you're
right
because of the video because she didn't
bring you
you didn't bring me the right coffee you
just [ __ ] you didn't bring me the
right coffee [ __ ] him pushing out the
ballpark
you just sweat you're just [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] you should swear
[ __ ] you you went in
i'm doing it for the win the [ __ ] i'm
just saying
it's like because it once again like i
had mentioned
you know the concept of trophy wives is
more focused on the man
than the women because it's in their
eyes it's like a possession it's a
prize that they value it literally means
that they
won the winner does not ask the trophy
how they feel
he claims it that's like a fish trying
to talk to a fisherman
about fishing just shut the [ __ ] up and
be a fish and i don't want it so if i
don't have a trophy wife that's not what
i want
but for the people that get into that
trophy
what you won you're the prize so of
course it's gonna be focused on the man
damn right god damn when i was in prison
we used to do a group in my cottage
which was the drug cottage and i
remember
our counselor miss smith we do a lot of
stuff on love because it was a women's
prison
so a lot of times women got sucked into
things with men trying to chase after
love
the reason why she's in prison is
because she loved a man too much
accountability what's that and i
remember she
held up a picture as a black and white
picture
and she said you want to be a full
by yourself you should already be a full
picture and then she held up another
picture
and it was the same picture but it was
colored in she says you
need to be the full picture by yourself
and once you complete that picture
you'll find someone who will bring color
to it that's amazing
if you're a trophy wife you have to be a
some kind of woman
and when you get to that point of a
woman you're gonna find someone that's
gonna be able to
hang that trophy on a wall i mean that
picture
i mean great analogy by the way
all right well here comes the porn star
ex-convict
who uh wants to tell you how to be a
high-value woman anyways
okay bro anyways okay
now that is it for today's video oh yes
do you have anything that you've taken
away with this
[ __ ] christ do you want to say
anything the delusion of people
listen um i got nothing else to add i've
done my job
wow wow
now people in jail can do whatever they
can achieve and say
but we're talking about trophy wife
trophy wife is the epiphany of the guy
that ha that can choose
he's got a status that he can choose
that's what it is
he's not necessarily looking for love so
why would he choose an ex-convict that
and those things are great and
everything and stuff but why would he do
that
why and guess what when you're talking
about yet a girl can be looking at how
she wants and then
the guy that's high value top tier
millionaire
takes that girl he's not gonna be a
trophy to his
peers and that's one of the points of a
trophy wife
that she looks good to other people not
just him
to other [ __ ] out there he
might want to choose her
but [ __ ] are like oh that's
your wife all right your ex convict when
he gonna go to the country club
they're gonna ride on his ass when the
wife is not there
trust how about i tell you and then she
doesn't become a trophy wife she gets
off the shelf they're not gonna go after
him for
for her being his convict they're going
to go after him because she got [ __ ]
by everybody on the block
yeah and then after that yo can i have a
go at your wife
and then he might lose opportunities
just because
he's with that person because he made a
poor decision
oh no you think what a you could think
what a trophy wife can be you could
think all of that good stuff
great but it's not what it is
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
so